une dernière étape avant leur vrai
baptême de feu aujourd'hui 72 jeunes
sapeurs pompiers de saône-et-loire
passent leur brevet une journée
importante stressante aussi pour ses
futurs pompiers
chaque évaluation se déroule en binôme
jodie et enzo sont plutôt satisfaits de
leur épreuve de simulation d'incendié
s'est super bien passé il ya eu un petit
peu de stress mais une fois alors dans
la manoeuvre ça passe ça passe et puis
après c'est super on se rend compte
qu'on a fait quelque chose
d'exceptionnel
peut-être que ce soir je pourrais avoir
j'espère mon brevet qui pourrait engager
après en tant que pompier volontaire ont
été envie de rentrer en caserne vide
quoi voilà c'est ça le plus vite
possible tous les deux savaient dès leur
plus jeune âge qui voulait devenir
pompier et pour réaliser leur vocation
tous ici doivent suivre quatre ans de
formation est passé avec succès les
épreuves d'aujourd'hui inondations
incendies échelle à positionner tous
leurs gestes sont évalués mais aussi
leurs connaissances et leur comportement
qu'est ce qu'il faut pour être un un bon
pompier sont vous c'est quoi les des
aptitudes l'envi l'envi et connaître son
métier de la persévérance toujours à
prendre
et puis après on fait avec en général
plus de 80% des jsp décrochent leur
diplôme et la profession attire toujours
autant d'adeptes
ils sont vingt jeunes de plus que
l'année dernière à tenter leur chance
un succès qui réjouit les pompiers plus
chevronnés je crois qu'il ya un
engouement aujourd'hui sur un retour un
petit peu à des activités qui soit
proche de la société qui soit proche de
l'engagement solidaire envers la
population et les jeunes sa part confié
en sont le reflet aujourd'hui les
sapeurs pompiers de saône et loire
compte 2200 professionnels et
volontaires et les membres de la
promotion 2010 8 des jsp espère bientôt
rentrer dans les rangs